abdul rasheed wades through water
several times a day to get essentials
his home has been flooded for days he
says he's tried getting help but
shelters are full and his family is
still waiting for government aid
we are facing many difficulties you can
see for yourself there's so much water
we have no way to get out there's barely
enough food we had some rice at home but
now that's also over
hundreds of thousands of other people
have been displaced by floods caused by
heavy rains in assam state in india's
north east
nagao district is the hardest hit more
than 300 000 people have been affected
the water here comes from a nearby river
that's overflowed and it's brought fish
that some villagers are catching to eat
despite the rising water levels many
people are choosing to stay back waiting
for the tide to turn so they can start
rebuilding
many people are being evacuated rafts
like these have been crossing flooded
roads and fields to rescue people
stranded for days
we are facing many problems some people
in my family are not keeping well i
asked them to come with me but they
didn't want to leave they wanted to stay
at home
the military is using aircraft and boats
to help distribute aid
the last flood was in 2004 the severe
one actually
after that
people just talk about that flood as the
highest one so the severity of the flood
is has surpassed that flood also now the
danger level of river here is 59.10
meters but it has across the danger
level it which is now 60.39 meters
although water levels are slowly
receding people are wary the monsoon
season will begin in a few weeks and the
rains are usually heavy and cause
flooding
pav nimittal al jazeera nagao district
in north east india